will have to close with more on the most
recent school shooting the parents of
the accused school shooter ethan crumley
could be charged as soon as today
crumbly who is 15 years old has been
charged as an adult for allegedly
killing four students and injuring seven
other people at his oxford michigan high
school in a statement the school
superintendent said it still looks like
a war zone and it will be weeks before
students can return nancy chen is in
oxford michigan following the
investigation nancy good morning
good morning the county prosecutor here
told me the suspect's parents should
have done a better job of securing the
weapon that was used in tuesday's attack
and that could have saved lives
100 it could have been prevented oakland
county prosecutor kara mcdonald said
justice is the reason her office charged
the alleged shooter ethan crumbly with
24 felony charges including one count of
terrorism what's behind that charge it
speaks for what really happened this is
not something that just happened
to to eight individuals this is
the footprint is large and it has a
ripple effect
we hear something that sounds like
someone being punched against a locker
seventeen-year-old catalina ifkovitz
credits her math teacher for saving
lives on tuesday the shooter was right
outside her classroom he was able to
shut the door immediately and get us all
in the lockdown mode if it hadn't been
for the teachers i don't know how many
more casualties there would have been to
say that i am
still
in shock and numb is probably an
understatement last night oxford
community schools superintendent tim
throne addressed the shooting in victims
we have parents that sent their kids to
school two days ago
and they're never coming home police say
the shooter used a semi-automatic
handgun purchased by his father just
days before tuesday's attack mcdonald is
investigating the alleged gunman's
parents for possible charges and what
could those potential charges look like
it went far beyond just a negligent
parent and
fully support
and advocate
holding them responsible if that meets
the
threshold and the elements are there
law enforcement officials tell us that
so far the parents are not cooperating
the suspect has pleaded not guilty to
all charges the superintendent also says
that there were no prior disciplinary
actions for the alleged shooter despite
a meeting on his behavior just hours
before the shooting
so much coming out of this nancy thank
you for your report